un journaliste violemment prise à partie
par la police frapper au sol c'est
arrivé ce lundi soir à la veille du vote
de la loi relative à la sécurité globale
à l'assemblée nationale alors qu'il
couvrait le délogement de 500 tentes de
migrants place de la république à paris
rémy buzine confrères de chez brut est
menacée pas moins de trois fois par un
policier en parallèle des centaines de
personnes sont expulsées de leurs tentes
parfois sous les tirs de gaz
lacrymogènes et de grenades de
désencerclement des images qui ont
provoqué l'indignation au sein de la
classe politique de gauche et
écologistes une manifestation pacifique
de migrants évacués il ya quelques jours
d'un camp à saint denis
aujourd'hui sans refuge chargés par la
police
je suis témoin de la violence contre des
manifestants dont le seul tort était
d'être présent place de la république
consternation et tristesse ce soir
devant cette évacuation violente de
migrants que l'état a laissé sans
solution d'hébergement
ce gouvernement manque à tous ses
devoirs à commencer par celui d'humanité
honte au pied de la république ce soir
l'inhumanité des tentes de réfugiés
arraché par les forces de l'ordre
une expulsion sans solution ce n'est ni
la liberté ni la fraternité face à tant
de violence gérald darmanin a réagi ce
matin et a saisi l'inspection générale
de la police nationale la police des
polices
le rapport du préfet de police sur
l'évacuation du campement illicite place
de la république m'a été remis ce matin
celui ci m'a proposé la saisine de
l'igpn sur plusieurs faits inacceptables
j'ai demandé à l'igpn de remettre ses
conclusions sous 48 heures et les
rendrait public
si le texte venait à être votée la loi
adopté de telles images ne pourrait plus
être diffusée